francés Emanuel macron se encuentra en
medio de uno de los mayores desafíos de
su mandato con la ira pública
desbordando una primera ministra en
apuros y la falta de mayoría absoluta en
el parlamento Cuáles son las opciones de
macron para resolver la crisis la
primera es una remodelación del gobierno
que sustituye a la primera ministra
Elizabeth burn una medida que sería un
alivio para el partido Francia en sumisa
dimita porque si no no habrá normalidad
Así que dimita
no es la única a la que señalan varios
ministros están siendo criticados a
Puerta cerrada Hay un problema en salud
vivienda educación la acción no es
viable dice un miembro del partido
movimiento democrático pero Fuentes
cercanas a macron dicen que una
remodelación no está en las cartas por
ahora otra opción disolver la asamblea
nacional
hay que volver al pueblo esperamos una
disolución porque es la mejor manera de
salir de esta crisis política y social
Pero es una opción a la que el jefe de
se opone y también los miembros de su
partido que temen que la disolución les
haga perder escaños podría ayudar a la
reagrupación nacional dice un miembro
otra posibilidad llevar a cabo reformas
es importante que el presidente de al
país su visión muestre la acción que
llevaremos a cabo para servir al pueblo
en las próximas semanas y meses
las reformas abordarían preocupaciones
cotidianas como los problemas que
afectan a los adultos mayores la mejora
de la igualdad de género o la vivienda
al parecer el presidente espera las
propuestas de sus ministros Y por
supuesto está el polémico plan de
reforma de las pensiones que macron
insisten convertir en ley a pesar de la
creciente oposición